what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by today and with
San Diego Comic-Con right around the
corner fans are wondering what exactly
does Marvel Studios have in store for us
not only at sdcc but simply with the
future of Marvel Studios in general now
sdcc is expected to be pretty big
there's a lot of updates that Marvel
needs to push out including an update of
the release schedule since some things
have been delayed or some shows have
swapped places with each other we really
do need an updated Phase 5 release
schedule just to know what expect right
now there are plenty of movies and shows
with no release date really attached to
them yet before we knew some were gonna
come in spring or summer but now
everything's kind of up in the air so
we're expecting to get some clarity
about this from Marvel Studios and of
course one of the biggest things is
phase six right now we only know four
movies that have been officially
announced to be coming out in phase six
that is Deadpool 3 The Fantastic Four
and our two new Avengers film films
Avengers the King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars however there have been some
reports and some rumors from some
insiders going around that are starting
to make us believe that phase six might
not be exactly what we expect it to be
and Marvel Studios might be doing
something that they've never really done
before we've talked about this briefly
in other videos but they might be doing
a sub phase within a phase now they
might not call it a sub phase it may
just be a part of the basic schedule but
this schedule is not going to be like
anything that we've seen before so we're
going to go over what exactly Marvel
Studios could be doing leading up to
Avengers Secret Wars talking about how
this could be a two-part event and what
we should expect to see leading up to
Secret Wars part 1 and what is going to
happen between part 1 and part 2 of
Secret Wars the end of the Multiverse
Saga so if you love Marvel and want to
stay up to date be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss any videos now if you're not aware
at this point we have had multiple
reports stating that Marvel Studios is
considering making Avengers Secret Wars
into a two-part film also with this if
it were to indeed happen would come as
we've mentioned before sort of a sub
phase of phase six and what's really
interesting about this subface is that
it wouldn't exactly take place in our
universe and this actually makes for a
possibly even better huge event for
Secret Wars because lately there has
been with the exception of Spider-Man
across the spider-verse kind of a bad
handle on Multiverse films a lot of them
get kind of confusing or don't have
enough time dedicated to certain aspects
of the story to really make it super
meaningful and an effective story and it
looks like this is what Marvel is trying
to avoid they want it all to make
perfect sense they want the continuity
to be Crystal Clear they want it to be
impactful and make for a great story and
they want it to be entertaining which is
why taking their time with the full
entire story of the ending of the
Multiverse Saga which is going to be all
about Kang and the multiversal war
taking time to tell this story is the
the perfect plan not rushing anything
but producing several projects all
related to the same story that are all
insanely good will make for an
incredible event I'm not talking about
one movie but a secret Wars event that
takes place in multiple different
universes consisting of multiple
different teams fighting separately and
then coming together that could be one
of the greatest things we'd ever see as
superhero fans and that is what it looks
like Marvel Studios is considering doing
by splitting up Avengers Secret Wars
into part 1 and part two and one of the
great things about this plan is that
after the King Dynasty leading up to
Secret Wars part 1 and everything
between part 1 and part two have the
potential to be completely new territory
for Marvel Studios one of the great
things about Marvel Studios is the
interconnectivity of the MCU and now
they have a chance to have that same
connectivity with multiple universes and
I think that a multiversal Avengers team
is about to be formed or a multiversal
illuminati team whatever the new hero
team is going to be I think it it's
about to be absolutely insane and I
think this team is going to consist of
some major characters that we've known
and loved over the past many years of
reading comic books and watching
animated shows and seeing the MCU and
the old Fox X-Men films the potential
for what this could be is so big for
example we already kind of know marvel
studios's plan for the X-Men we already
know that in Deadpool 3 we are going to
see other universes because Deadpool and
Wolverine are kind of gonna go on a
multiversal road trip and there have
already been reports from several
insiders stating that many of the
original X-Men are going to be returning
for Deadpool 3. well apparently Marvel
Studios also has the same plan for
Avengers Secret Wars but not just the
actual movie but leading up to the movie
and possibly in between part one and
part two this is how it'll work leading
up to this multiversal new hero team
Avengers the King Dynasty is basically
Avengers Infinity War it might not be on
that big of a scale because the King
Dynasty isn't Meant To Be A Part 1 to a
two-part adventure with Secret Wars
being the second part that wasn't really
what Marvel Studios is going for however
Infinity war and Avengers endgame were
originally announced as a part 1 and a
part 2 but the Kang Dynasty will be very
similar to Avengers Infinity War due to
the fact that at the end of the King
Dynasty Kang is gonna win and yes
eventually The Avengers and the X-Men
Fantastic Four and any other Heroes out
there are going to fight Kang and his
multiple variants across multiple
different universes but if what Marvel
Studios is planning is true then we are
going to visit these other universes in
movies that take place between the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars and if there is
a secret Wars part 1 and part 2 they
will continue to explore other universes
between part 1 and part two that means
we could have solo movies or Disney Plus
shows taking place in Another Universe
showing us different variants of Kang
affecting other universes destroying
other universes and if you want to look
into the actual Secret Wars events from
the comics be sure to check out my
buddies over at comicbookdirect.com they
have created a website and company that
makes comic book shopping the easiest it
can possibly be they deliver Comics
straight to your door you can get
one-off Comics or you can sign up for an
entire run and get a pretty big discount
if you do so and they'll ship the latest
issue right to your door each week they
have the latest from Marvel if you're
trying to keep up to date with all the
recent projects they have the latest
from DC as well and it's an all-in-one
shop for your Comics everything that you
need in one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below it is absolutely amazing that
we are getting the secret Wars event in
the MCU and again the potential for this
is crazy for example Reed Richards
exists in our universe we know that the
Fantastic Four are coming unless the
Fantastic Four is a movie that is going
to take place in another universe but I
don't think that's the case at all so
Reed Richards Mr Fantastic right now is
in our universe we haven't met him yet
but he does exist and he's the smartest
man alive that's his thing and we know
that he exists in other universes as
well we saw him in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of madness he was a part of
the Illuminati and he was introduced
again as the smartest man alive well
here's something that I would absolutely
love to see in some way shape or form
happen between the King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars and that is Reed
Richards reaching out to other universes
in an attempt to try and stop the
multiversal war and the destruction of
the Multiverse because universes are
going to have to work together if
they're going to want to defeat Kang and
all of his variants and it's kind of
going to be the same thing that King
went through when he first discovered
that other universities existed and he
visited them and then universes started
to visit each other and they started to
help each other out and help each other
get more advanced until eventually some
of them turned on each other it'll
probably be exactly the same for all of
our heroes they're gonna reach out to
each other try to help each other maybe
share some technology some Weaponry but
I'm sure we're gonna see some evil
variants as well and I'm actually really
hoping that we do I think that would be
really cool to include in the story I'm
still looking at that Superior Iron Man
Tom Cruise to blame him and be an evil
Iron Man at some point in time in the
Multiverse so this is what we could see
and what I hope to see other universes
dealing with the threat that is Kang and
the multiversal extinction plus we're
also going to start to see incursions
happening universes running into other
universes so seeing variants deal with
their other variances universes
colliding into their own and what
exactly will they do when that happens
well that's what could happen between
Secret Wars part 1 and part 2 a battle
world event where a lot of incursions
happen and we essentially have you
Universal refugees seeking shelter in
other universes and we could have a
movie based off of this we could have a
Disney plus series based off of this and
multiple other movies as well based off
of other superhero teams like the
Illuminati like the X-Men like the
Fantastic Four like the Avengers of
other universes the potential is really
infinite here because the Multiverse is
essentially infinite so who knows what
crazy things we could see if you have
something in mind that you think you
would love to see happen in our universe
or Another Universe or with both of them
coming together let us know your
thoughts down below what would you like
to see between the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars and if there is a part 2 of
Secret Wars what would you like to see
between part 1 and part two let us know
all your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and leave a comment because
this enters you in our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month also we are on patreon now we also
have a website that we post to multiple
times a day and we have a Discord server
we'll link all of those in the
description down below and of course you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
as well as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf
baby